ce sont des scènes devenues habituelles
amis collègues depuis deux semaines les
habitants de cette ville du sud de
l'ukraine sont condamnés à se procurer
de l'eau de manière quotidienne la
guerre ayant endommagé les
infrastructures qui acheminer l'eau de
la ville voisine de ré sonne désormais
son occupation russe
je dois venir chercher de l'autre tous
les jours bien sûr que je veux que les
choses aillent ce n'est pas normal de ne
pas avoir d'eau dans un pays européen
ici nous sommes sûr ni terre nous avons
attaqué personne avant vivait une vie
normale et tout allait bien
le gros problème ce sont les gens qui ne
peuvent pas physiquement aller chercher
de l'eau par eux mêmes qui sont coincés
chez eux les personnes âgées et les
handicapés alors on essaye d'avoir de
l'eau pour nous est de les aider ensuite
réfugiée
derrière ce mur une source d'eau il
s'agit de l'un des onze forage que les
autorités de nicolas ly ont creusé dans
la ville pour étancher la soif de ses
habitants cependant des forages à eux
seuls ne suffisent pas face aux besoins
importants de la population des
initiatives privées ont vu le jour voir
cette compagnie a décidé de mettre à
disposition des habitants une autre
transporté depuis au dessin un signe de
solidarité très apprécié en ces temps de
guerre
c'est comme ça il y à de l'eau à odessa
il signe en a pas tout le monde tient le
coup du mieux qu'il peut que je pense
qu'il faut aider les gens on n'habite
pas loin
seul pays il faut centrer
cependant pour beaucoup d'ukrainiens la
russie essaie de briser cette unité le
maire de nicolas yves soupçonnent
l'armée russe d'avoir intentionnellement
cibler les infrastructures hydrauliques
avec un seul objectif en tête de créer
un problème écologique ou quelque chose
comme ça le ministère de la défense
russe a écrit sur son site internet
qu'il y a un problème à nicolas yves que
beaucoup de gens ici meurent à cause de
maladies causées par le manque d'eau
pour l'instant la population de micola
yves fait preuve d'une très grande
résilience alors que les autorités
locales mettent tout en oeuvre pour
rétablir l'eau ne serait ce que pendant
quelques heures par jour ces mêmes
autorités poussent les habitants à
quitter la ville ici l'inquiétude est
grandissante face à une intensification
très probable des combats